hey everyone is cereth register nurse
sorry and common in this video i'm gonna
demonstrate how to put on and take off
an n95 respirator before dawning or
putting on an n95 respirator you always
want to follow the manufacturer's
instructions also you want to follow
your facility's protocol for getting
fitted for your n95 respirator and this
is usually done yearly but it can vary
first what you want to do is you want to
perform hand hygiene hold the respirator
in one hand with the front of the
respirator touching the inside of your
hand the metal nose piece should rest
near the fingertips be sure the top and
bottom straps of the respirator are
hanging down below your hand and are not
tangled or twisted take the respirator
and place it over your nose mouth and
under the chin hold the respirator in
place with one hand use your free hand
to place the straps on your head it's
very important the straps rest on the
head and that they are not overlapping
or tangled first take the top strap of
the respirator and place it just past
the top of your head above the ears then
take the bottom strap of the respirator
and place it around the bottom of the
head just below the ears again make sure
the straps are not crossing or are
overly twisted to ensure a proper seal
of the respirator around the nose area
use the fingertips of both hands to bend
the metal nose piece around the nose
starting in the center and working your
way outward on each side now perform the
seal test this is performed to check if
you have donned the respirator correctly
and that it does not leak air always
follow the manufacturer's guidelines for
this part because it can vary between
brands first place both hands over the
respirator then take a sharp breath in
and make sure the respirator is sealing
over the face during inhalation keep
both hands on the respirator breathe out
while breathing out make sure you feel
for air leakage around the nose piece
and around the respirators perimeter
if leaking air around the nose piece try
rebuilding the nose piece with both
hands and recheck the seal if air is
leaking around the respirators perimeter
try readjusting the straps and recheck
again make sure the respirator is not
being affected by any piercings facial
hair and glasses which
prevent a proper seal if respirator
still leaks after this you may need a
different size or type of respirator
before use
now it's Adolphe or take off the mask
two things you want to remember is that
you don't want to touch the front of the
mask because it's considered
contaminated but you can touch the
straps of the mask because these are
considered clean first you will take
your hands and you will remove the
bottom strap by pulling it over the head
then you will take the top strap and
pull it over the head be very careful
not to touch the mask now you can
dispose or reuse the mask depending on
your facility's protocol and then
perform hand hygiene okay so that wraps
up this video on how to dawn and dolphin
n95 respirator and be sure to check out
the other videos in this series